[Music]
Despicable Me was first released in 2010
and the directors never imagined it
would turn into such worldwide obsession
from extra movies to accessories and
cosplays these are some of the most
popular characters on the planet wait
until you see what a real-life GRU looks
like don't forget to subscribe to our
Channel and give this video a big thumbs
up today we're checking out 10
Despicable Me characters in real life
Eggman let's start with the youngest of
the bunch you can't deny that Agnes is
one of the most adorable characters out
there we're sure many can relate to her
love for fluffy unicorns in the movie
the character was voiced by Elsie Fisher
who was only 7 years old while she was
working on the first movie Agnes is an
adorable six-year-old and the youngest
of the three sisters adopted by group
just like any other six-year-old she has
her sneaky ways of getting what she
wants Agnes tends to hold her breath
until you bring her whatever she asks
for isn't that just typical of children
her age she's also incredibly loving and
has no trouble befriending practically
anyone including the vicious dog even
Gru's reluctant to come close to Agnes
has dark hair that's put up in a
standing buddha tail and denim overalls
you think it would be hard to look like
her in real life but this cutie is
rocking the Agnes look from the ponytail
and the red headband to the cute
overalls and a yellow shirt this child
could easily play a human version of
Agnes speaking of real-life things from
Despicable Me do you remember the book
sleepy kitten it's available for
purchase and it's the replica of the
book that GRU reads to the girls if you
have some Despicable Me fans in the
family then this is an absolute must
product to get Edith Edith is one of
those Care
you instantly fall in love with she
refuses to show that she's happy and
gets a thrill from putting herself in
daring situations in the movie she has
some of the best one-liners that are
usually followed by an eye-roll
Edith is a nine year old girl with blue
eyes and blonde hair she always sports a
pink beanie and is dressed in an all
pink outfit out of the three sisters
she's the one that's usually the most
pessimistic and doesn't trust people
straight away but we can't help but to
love her sarcastic personality and watch
as GRU eventually wins over her heart
Edith is voiced by Dana Geyer who was 13
when the first Despicable Me came on the
big screen Edith is a fun character to
cosplay and there are plenty of people
out there that manage to recreate a
human version of the sassy nine-year-old
check out this girl who nailed the Edith
look to look like Edith all you need is
a pink beanie purple skirt pink leggings
and some snow boots
you'll also need to be extremely daring
and master the art of eye rolling and
adults and you'll be able to recreate
her look our next character is the
oldest of the three sisters and the one
that always has to keep everyone calm
she's smart and witty and she doesn't
put up with any nonsense Margo Margo is
the older sister everyone wishes they
could have she's very protective of
Agnes and Edith but she also disapproves
of Edith whenever she misbehaves just
like Edith she also has a sarcastic
sense of humor
although she's a bit more optimistic it
took a while for GRU to win her over and
we can't blame her for not trusting the
minions from the beginning although
she's only 12 years old Margo is very
mature for her age she can easily
outsmart GRU as well as other characters
she is voiced by Miranda Cosgrove who is
better known for her role on iCarly to
look like Margo you have to have brown
hair and put it in a ponytail she is
often seen wearing a black t-shirt with
a white button shirt underneath a brown
jacket applied skirt and red sneakers
and don't forget about those glasses a
deviantART user who goes by the nickname
poem Oh burn
artists decided to cosplay as Margo and
she totally nailed it she certainly did
an amazing job at looking like the older
Despicable Me sister cosplayers really
can pull off just about any look
including the one we're about to show
you who's your favorite character out of
the three sisters is it Agnes Margot or
eat it or maybe it's our next colorful
lady Lucy Wilde Lucy Wilde doesn't
appear until the second Despicable Me
movie she's on a mission to take GRU out
and we don't mean out for a date
although that is what happens after the
two realized they are just absolutely
perfect for each other
and Edith Margot and Agnes get a new
mother she is voiced by the talented and
hilarious Kristen Wiig Lucy is an
unusual character when it comes to her
looks and she easily stands out from the
crowd
perhaps this is why it's so hard to
believe she's a secret agent in disguise
she has bright orange hair and can be
seen wearing a long light blue coat that
doesn't fit in with the crowd
she owns ridiculous gadgets such as a
moose tranquilizer and a lipstick taser
which is probably why she's such a
perfect match for groom her character is
a fun one to recreate and we love this
cosplayers version of Lucy her username
on deviantART is madam paradox cosplay
and she's serious from male Lucy's look
she even managed to find the same white
high heels and they look absolutely
gorgeous so we now have for Despicable
Me real-life characters and it's time to
add a couple of villains to this
colorful mix vector vectors the man with
both direction and magnitude those were
his words of course not ours he's voiced
by Jason Segel and he's one of those
characters you want to dislike but can't
vectors always trying to ruin
rude plans and most of the time he's
outsmarted by everyone including Agnes
Edith and Margo
unlike GRU who had a tough upbringing
Becker is a spoiled child who always
gets what he wants he has a funny look
that's pretty hard to recreate you'll
never see him without his orange suit
glasses and his bowl haircut although
he's supposed to be a villain vector is
a hilarious character with plenty of
scenes that will make you laugh out loud
remember the scene where he shrinks the
toilet with the shrink ray and then the
toilet had its revenge his fabulous look
recreated in real life by Sheree 81 a
cosplayer from Germany yep that's right
she's a girl and she was able to create
a realistic human version of vector
we've covered a lot of cosplayers on our
channel and we're starting to think that
cosplaying should be considered a
superpower we really want to know where
she got her outfit from because she
managed to look a million times better
than Despicable Me villain miss patty
miss Hattie is the only Despicable Me
character that no one has ever decided
to cosplay but today we'll show you how
you can easily recreate miss Hattie in
real life in case you can't remember who
she is
here's a quick lowdown of everything you
need to know about this gloomy character
she appears in the first Despicable Me
movie and she runs the orphanage where
Agnes Margot and Edith stated before
they got adopted
miss Hattie is a parody of Miss Hannigan
from Annie so it's safe to say she
wasn't made to be a friendly character
here's what you'll need to dress as miss
Hattie find a purple plaid skirt that
goes just slightly over your knees grab
a pink long-sleeved shirt buy high heels
and put your hair up in a 60s hairstyle
after that make sure you hate children
and be really arrogant towards people
and you'll easily become miss Hattie
there is a character that could very
well be miss Patty's twin sister as the
resemblance is uncanny
do you remember Dolores Umbridge the
strict kitten loving professor
of the Defense Against the Dark Arts
from Harry Potter
don't they totally look alike we can't
decide which one we dislike the most GRU
and you can't leave out GRU a
self-proclaimed world's greatest villain
whose plan was to steal the moon just to
prove his point he has interesting
helpers but will tell you all about them
later GRU is brilliantly voiced by Steve
Carell and he's one of the most
interesting Despicable Me characters out
there we're sure you all know what he
looks like so here's a cosplayer that
managed to recreate a real-life version
of this X super villain we all know
Steve Carell is a funny guy but this
might be the best thing he's ever done
Steve decided to dress up his crew and
he managed to create the best cosplay
version ever he has the scarf the jacket
and he definitely has that GRU look
complete with a pointy nose he even
appeared on The Ellen Show as GRU and
did a hilarious interview if there ever
is a despicable Me character in real
life that deserves an award it's Steve
Carell what do you think you'd do if you
ever met the actual GRU he seems like a
funny character what if he'd want to
freeze you with his Stingray maybe
that's why he needs our next character
who's the brain behind Gru's amazing
gadgets dr. Nefario
dr. Nefario charmed us all with his
amazing accent and cheerful personality
he's voiced by Russell Brand and he's
just fabulous
he's GRU so-called sidekick but really
he just likes to create different
gadgets even if they make no sense
remember when he created boogie robots
instead of cookie robots or sent a
minion floating up in space he's a
pretty special character but a very fun
one to recreate check out this picture
of the entire office dressing up as GRU
dr. Nefario and the minions those are
some office goals right there to look
like dr. Nefario you'll need to put on
your best goggles a white doctor suit
black boots black gloves plaid pants and
a portable mobility scooter then you
need to sound like Russell Brand and
start inventing you
gadgets befriend someone that looks like
GRU and voila you're a real-life dr.
Nefario some fan theories state the dr.
Nefario was cruised father we never know
the story of his father but people
suspected it might be him as they share
similar noses this theory got debunked
with a picture of a family tree that
shows Gru's father's name is Robert our
next characters were first introduced to
the girls as his cousins but they
managed to become so much more than that
minions the minions are some of the most
popular characters in the world they're
loud they're obnoxious and they have
their very own language that somehow
makes sense even though you don't really
know what they're saying although you
can't find the true versions of the
minions in real life because we're not
yet sure what kind of creatures they are
making costumes exist and these people
are putting them to good use it's not
just people who love the minions check
out this dog in this cat rocking their
costume these yellow characters manage
to take over the whole world
they even got their very own movie and a
video game we're sure they're not
stopping anytime soon in dispute a
Stewart Jerry Kevin mark Phil Carl and
Josh some of the best minion scenes
include them laughing at Josh printing
his butt Dave getting excited and
accidentally firing a rocket launcher
and the scene from Despicable Me 2 where
Stuart and Dave laugh at Silas
Ramsbottom name what can we say it's
tough not to love these yellow creatures
they're voiced by the movies animator
Pierre coffin who actually gave voice to
899 different minion characters to this
day yes you heard that right there are
almost 1,000 minions out there are you a
fan of minions or are you getting tired
of the craze all the despicable Me
characters together need a tip how to
create quality family time spend some
time creating Despicable Me costumes and
convince your entire family to play a
character you think it's crazy but this
family did it and it looks awesome and
here they are all Despicable Me
life characters in one single picture
who would have thought that you could
actually make a pretty impressive family
portrait if you dress up as a popular
movie franchise check it out it's Agnes
Edith Margaux vector and of course GRU
we're very impressed by their outfits
and it seems like they really paid
attention to every single detail made
the characters come to life this family
portrait belongs to Annie who was so set
on creating costumes for her children
her husband even said he'll shave his
head to pose as GRU now that's some real
dedication right there
we are completely in love with this
portrait and out of all real-life
characters we've shown you today this
one is our favorite the only things
they're missing are minions or dr.
Nefario but since the two are rarely
seen outside the house it's safe to
assume they are still somewhere out
there we're already planning how we're
going to convince our families to dress
up as these characters and recreate
hilarious Despicable Me scenes give this
video a thumbs up for minions and don't
forget to subscribe to our channel
looking for more videos featuring
Despicable Me characters check out 10
Disney Princesses reimagined as minions
see you next time
[Music]
you